a
[Música]
ah
la mayoría de los destinos turísticos de
arena y sol en méxico estarán abiertos
durante la semana santa para recibir a
paseantes nacionales y extranjeros si
bien algunas playas como las de chiapas
estarán cerradas al público el resto
como las de quintana roo oaxaca guerrero
jalisco nayarit o baja california
permitirán el ingreso eso sí con un
aforo limitado al 50% y estrictas
medidas sanitarias aunque el
cumplimiento de éstas estará por verse
ya que durante el más reciente fin de
semana largo con motivo del 21 de marzo
lucieron abarrotadas las playas de
acapulco o playa del carmen de
visitantes nacionales o de spring
breakers en sonora por ejemplo se pedirá
a los paseantes la prueba negativa de
ccoo bit para poder ingresar a los
balnearios el secretario de turismo
federal miguel torruco dijo que esta es
una oportunidad histórica para recuperar
al sector después del golpe recibido por
la pandemia y dijo que se estima recibir
una derrama económica de cerca de los
seis mil millones de dólares
[Música]
la semana santa promete el arribo masivo
de turistas a las playas del pacífico de
nicaragua con el impulso de un plan
verano de parte del gobierno central que
promete más de 1000 actividades de
recreación y entretenimiento para las
familias nicaragüenses a nivel nacional
el instituto de turismo ha dicho que la
vacuna contra el comida ayudaría a
generar confianza a los turistas
nacionales y extranjeros y el ministerio
de salud ha prometido inspecciones
sanitarias durante la semana santa la
presidente daniel ortega se refirió por
primera vez desde la llegada de la
pandemia en un año y dijo que las
personas deben evitar contagios tomando
las medidas sanitarias su gobierno fue
el único a nivel centroamericano que no
tomó ningún tipo de cuarentena o
restricción alguno para evitar la
pandemia de coronavirus recientemente
costa rica anunció la reapertura de su
frontera terrestre con nicaragua lo que
significaría un importante flujo
migratorio en los próximos días
[Música]
en costa rica los casos de kobe 19 han
disminuido en las últimas semanas de
registrar más de 1000 casos diarios a
finales de 2020 hoy día se reportan unos
400 es por eso que las autoridades han
flexibilizado las medidas de restricción
de movilidad para las vacaciones de
semana santa no habrá restricciones
extra eso si el gobierno llamó a la
ciudadanía a vacacionar responsablemente
tomando en cuenta todos los protocolos
sanitarios se pretende aprovechar esta
temporada de vacaciones para ayudar a la
recuperación del sector turismo uno de
los más afectados y de los más
importantes ya que constituye el 82 por
ciento del producto interno bruto esta
semana además se anunció la reapertura
de las fronteras terrestres para
turistas al sur con panamá y al norte
con nicaragua las que tenían un año de
permanecer clausuradas como medida de
prevención ante la pandemia el
relajamiento de las medidas parece haber
animado a una parte de la población a
retomar algunas actividades con el uso
de mascarilla por eso los negocios
turísticos esperan este empuje económico
tras la crisis con la ayuda del turismo
nacional
[Música]